I work this place near one pane and the
blink learn are just fire everywhere and
then charging out of these flames
comes us they're far the most beautiful
and terrible fun remember see
I heard you guys had some spots
available you lost and got one slot open
you know what we're training for
hotshots get to engage the fire directly
the ceiling game six with Firebug if you
give me a chance I'll let you down
sooner or later fires going to come out
in our hometown in trying to broker for
years we've got all our hours all our
qualifications but until we're certified
hotshots my crew won't even be able to
step foot on the line Acco there would
be easy anyone being John Gotti for
sharing now
the cool sticker he's not
[Music]
which all debris then this beautiful
Vista is never going to be able to look
out of the walls
see that pure beauty is
thank you greatest job in the world I
don't know what
fire threatens homes in people's life
I'm a friend of now there is your hot
shop
I've got a daughter and I just really
want to get around
if I get half our line in goes our town
earn our second two ways can feel like
the end of the world as long as you can
breathe survive
fairly seen for the past few months
sorry
are they now
y'all here
no one could be prouder of his boy than
I am of you guys don't piece of me
coming in
you